if you took the words and you replaced
Rosie for Ronald there would be a
objectification of women in the
workplace and so that is disturbing and
it's wrong Elisabeth Hasselbeck has a
message for her former The View co-host
Rosie O'Donnell and whether you're a man
or whether a woman and you're
objectifying woman in the workplace it's
wrong yep the former Fox and Friends
host returned to her old show on Tuesday
and weighed in on Rosie O'Donnell
revealing she had a crush on her during
their time together on the ABC talk show
I'll be very honest I read it I mean
they started praying because I'm like
how I'm gonna handle this and my old
self would be another split screen
moment that split screen moment that
she's referring to was a superheated
on-air debate between Rosie and
Elizabeth in 2007 about the Iraq war
that quickly turned personal and led to
Rosie quitting do not I sit here every
single day over my heart and tell people
exactly what I believe Oh Delilah's
gonna call me a coward really well I'm
glad to hear Elizabeth isn't going on a
split screen this time around
me too but Elizabeth had a lot more to
say in response to Rosie whose remarks
are part of an upcoming book about the
daytime chat fest ladies who punch the
explosive inside story of the view in
the book Rosie says that despite the
tension on set she actually quote loved
Elizabeth and when fellow view co-host
Joy Behar made comments that O'Donnell
might have had a crush on Hasselbeck
O'Donnell didn't exactly shut it down
she said quote I think there were
underlying lesbian undertones on both
parts I think this is something that
will hurt her if you write it
she was the MVP of a Division one
softball team for two years that won the
finals there are not many in my life
girls with such athletic talent on
sports teams that are traditionally male
that aren't at least a little bit gay
while Elizabeth wasn't really filling
Rosie's generalizations about female
athletes that's an unfair stereotype and
it's seems selfish in a way and I think
that it's untrue in the expose Rosie
makes sure to clarify that her feelings
for Elizabeth were not sexual I wanted
to support raise elevate her like she
was a freshman star shortstop and I was
a cow
ten of the team since the excerpts from
the book were made public Elizabeth says
she tried to get in touch with Rosie to
talk it out I tried to call her
yesterday her number is old the one on
my phone and all she may not have gotten
a hold of her old co-star she says she's
letting it go so Rosie I think it was
disturbing to read those things and it
was offensive to me but I forgive her I
totally forgive you Rosie and I think
that I really hope that we can be at
peace and that we can have both hold our
beliefs in one hand and hold each
other's hands and the other and still
have a relationship that's a peace
Elizabeth is singing a way friendlier
tune these days in 2014 just one year
after she was reportedly fired from the
view today is officially my last day at
the view Elizabeth made it clear there
was still bad blood between her and
Rosie when she trashed her former
co-stars brief returns to the daytime
show during a phone interview with Fox &
Friends talk about not securing the
border here in comes to the view the
very woman who been in the face of our
military but in the face of her own
network and really in the face of a
person who stood by Herod had civilized
debate for the time that she was there
this is a lot of drama to digest and I
have a feeling that it's far from over
of course we'll spill all the tea so be
sure to subscribe to all things et until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens and I'm
Courtney teza know bye for now guys